wir müssen natürlich noch kurz filtern
das 4 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
[Musik]
sieht man sich gerade ja ja nein
hey leute was geht ab 1 willkommen beim
neuen video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich
geht es allen gut ich habe mir gedacht
passend zum thema richtig mir hier mal
gerade spontan an den lippen und hat
eine location in meinem zimmer ein also
weil hier gibt's halt nicht so viel in
diesem zimmer außer kartons und
schreibtisch im schrank und ein bett und
ein sofa also gibt's eigentlich schon
viel ja vor zwei tagen gab es ihm ein
video 100% zufällig bei uns bestellen
das ist echt gut angekommen das war das
erste video meines lebens als jemals in
den youtube trends war
warum weiß ich immer noch nicht
aber danke und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht weil ihr diese videos
anscheinend so schön findet die wisch
sachen dann übrigens noch nicht da mir
wurde auch gesagt das kann gern immer
zwei drei monate dauern stand zumindest
unter dem video wir machen heute einen
neuen park auf dem letzten video die
8000 leicht geschafft deswegen sage ich
heute bei 10.000 like zum nächsten
partner lasse ich mir was noch
interessanteres einfallen
und ja ich würde sagen wir fangen sofort
aber gar nicht lange heute geht es um
ebay
wir bestellen heute allerdings also in
köln challenge daraus heute geht es
nicht um alle produkte sondern heute
geht es um luxus marken weil das ding
ist ich glaube er ist somit eine der
einzigen plattform wo es alle
luxusmarken auch wenig dass im
originalen zustand gibt auch amazon ist
halt dann alles gefälscht ich und mein
macbook und dann würde ich sagen fangen
wir an so wie wir befinden uns jetzt
nach einigen anmelde schwierigkeiten
hier endlich auf der plattform ebay ebay
gibt es ja auch schon extrem lange
früher war immer extrem in ich habe
allerdings doch nie was über ebay
bestellt sondern erst so bei amazon kann
man so ein bisschen halt dieser online
bestellung deshalb glaube ich ja aber
ebay gibt es immer noch und hier gibt es
echt viele sachen deswegen würde ich
sagen marie hinter der kamera hat ganz
viele luxusmodemarken oder luxuswagen
von euch genannt bekommen hat sie
aufgeschrieben das prinzip ist ganz
einfach für die die es noch nicht wissen
also die letzten videos nicht geschaut
haben ich verlinke euch allerdings am
ende sie sagt mir gleich zum beispiel
eine marke dann kommt der
zufallsgenerator zum einsatz der würfel
beispielsweise die zahl acht und dann
muss ich das achte produkt das wir hier
angezeigt wird kaufen und verkaufen
ungefähr zehn produkte und am ende haben
wir dann wieder eine ziemlich große
auswahl an irgendwelchen schrott der
heute vielleicht ganz cool wird also
leute wir fangen an mit der ersten luxus
modemarke und das ist
ich würde es natürlich auch nicht helfen
aber einerseits feiere ich wirklich 0
das ist gar nicht mal so teuer
eigentlich ein metzger dass wir wirklich
zwölfte produkt wir haben ihre schuhe
von versace für 74 euro das günstigste
produkt nein das ist das erste produkt 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 original versace herren
pullover mit logo größe l schwarz schutz
vor wie teuer es kommt darauf an es gibt
dieses die fünf euro das ist doch nicht
um gnade wörtlich es gibt ja das sagt
man doch gar nicht schon vor als
original verkaufen nein ach so
entschuldigung ich muss mal grad ich
habe das system von ebay total vergessen
es ist natürlich es wird hoch geboten ja
ja ja und gerade ist das bei 55 ach so
dann müssen wir gucken dass das ein
produkt ist was man sofort kommen kann
sag ich mal wenn es jetzt das neueste
produkt nicht zum sofort kaufen gibt
nimmt man halt das 13
doch glaube ich auch filtern oder ach so
das ist eine gute du hast recht wusste
ich so jetzt haben wir es aber hier 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 und versace
designer teppich für 100 euro so wir
gehen das hier mal auf den designer
teppich aktion ewert mal wir brauchen
den in größe wir nehmen einfach die
kleinste größe
den gibt es auch für 25 euro genehmigt
kleinste größe kostet 25 euro und den
warenkorb designt habe ich modernen
versace glitzer gala jetzt hab ich es
wahrscheinlich fake ich wusste gar nicht
dass wir jetzt auch schon so weit sind
teppiche zu faken was noch so beruflich
völlig okay als nächstes mit louie vito
auch meine lieblingsmarken nicht jetzt
habe ich wahrscheinlich eine tasche ein
2.000 euro okay dass sie wollte brück
wir müssen natürlich noch kurz filtern
das wird 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
[Musik]
louie vito liverpool
dass die tasche die ich habe glaube ich
glaube so war ja doch das ist ich glaube
jetzt sogar nochmal größer meintest du
nicht die heute 1000 euro kostet das ist
ja auch das geht ja auch gebraucht aber
ich glaube das ist noch eine nummer
größer hätte doch ok ende warenkorb ich
bin echt mal gespannt wie teuer das
sollte wird okay nächste sache bitte
giorgio armani
was sollte man aber gibt georgia ein
weil sie wird das geschrieben ach so
giorgio armani gibt es hier schon ja
genau
ok und zwar so warte warte warte und
warte noch mal kurz das schlüsselprodukt
123 auch das ist ja ein schnäppchen 1999
deutsche armani acqua di gio sie etwas
für männer sogar echt mal papa ich hab
kein einzelgänger für alexa schnäppchen
aber ganz schön teuer aber diese schule
jetzt mal ohne wird sein ich werde sehen
welche findest du schön so was nennt die
will ich das ist ja grausam
die kannst du sofort kaufen will 380
euro zwar sei das zweite auf 12 hier
kannst du mit dem vergleicht was anfang
okay wir machen weiter die sechs zu
setzen
hier hast du doch auch schon oder 123456
die selbst noch nie highheels 170 euro
hinzu übrigens sollte schritt war bitte
ganz viele artikel egal was jede chance
in die kommentare
ihr könnt kommentieren fußball hier
können kommentieren dünn aus der box
keine ahnung irgendwie sowas halt
einfach für den nächsten partner mit ich
schon mal wieder kommentare ab die ich
benutzen kann und wir kommen zur
nächsten sache okay das wievielte 19 11
12 original channel original chanel
bombe einzelstück windbreaker die finde
ich echt geil ich meine für 350 euro
kannst du doch schon mal mitnehmen oder
also ich finde die gar nicht mal so
schlecht
nur für 350 euro würde ich die niemals
kaufen jetzt haben wir schon 123456
produkte im warenkorb und sind bereits
2.000 323 euro
ferrari heute war ich hab mir das
einfach ich gekauft aber nur weil es im
angebot waren eigentlich ist es so
richtig so richtig möchtegern meister
du kannst dir so ein t shirt davon aber
ich finde das echt ganz gut verarbeitet
und es sieht ganz lässig aus deswegen
habe ich das mal mitgenommen
das war eine kooperation zwischen kuba
und ferrari glaube ich so viel war da
achte produkt nicht gefällt
ich glaube hier geht es aber eher um
sportwagen als um irgendwelche klamotten
einfach so manchmal sagen kann dass wir
nochmal 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
[Musik]
wenn man stellt ist recklinghausen das
ist hier in der nähe ist ja schon mal
gut dann kann ich den ja gleich wir
haben hier einen ferrari testarossa für
schätzen wie viel mehr richtig dummen da
hinein kann doch sein dass du sogar
richtig liegt
150000 bist du gar nicht mal schlecht
136000 das ding ist ich glaube den kann
ich leider nicht beziehungsweise wird es
auch gar nicht wohin wenn das geld hätte
ich hab das geld ob man nicht okay da ja
das kann ich leider nicht hinzufügen
wir machen weiter mit denen mit der
nächsten luxusmarke ich glaub mir gucci
und prada und trage es mir gefällt
denn bei wie du bist und ich habe geld
aber ja ich schaue ich auf den preis es
war übrigens nur ein zitat von moneyball
okay das hebelprodukt das zehnte 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 original prada tasche
farbverlauf android als wenn du eine
prada tasche nur 169 euro kosten
die kasteler karenina ist bestimmt so
also ist sie schon hart gebraucht oder
die wird wahrscheinlich schon einmal ins
klo gedrängt und runter gespielt und
kann ich auch nicht in meinen warenkorb
tun
ja wieso eigentlich nicht leute
irgendwie konnte ich das auch nicht denn
kommt tun deswegen gehen wir jetzt
weiter zur nächsten produkt ja komm wir
würden das geschrieben
dollar
ja also ein stella mccartney fabela
geldbörse portemonnaie in den warenkorb
das obere falsche philipp plein ohne
witz also ich finde
philipp lahm hat in sachen die sind
total scheiße weg die würde ich niemals
kaufen aber so zehn prozent der sachen
sind übelste
nein herr und sweatshirt lang am kapuze
so das ist zb eine sache die würde ich
niemals kaufen einfach weil es mir
erstens nicht steht und zweitens mir
nicht 215 dollar macht mir nichts 215
euro wert ist als ich würde sagen wir
gucken uns jetzt mal kurz unseren
warenkorb an
wir haben hier ein designer hat habe ich
von versace louis vitton die zumindest
aus bünde tüte louis vuitton tasche
giorgio armani prof das ist das
günstigste mit abstand 19 euro valencia
giuseppe zanotti high heels original
chanel bombe
stella mccartney portemonnaie und
philipp plein pulli so das ding ist
viele fragen unter den videos immer alex
wirklich schutz vor wie teuer alles
zusammen ist 1641 geht voll oder ich
hätte eigentlich mehr erwarte ich dachte
da kommt am ende so 5000 raus viele
haben wir gesagt haben kauft die sache
noch wenig das ding ist das habe ich im
ersten video hiervon erklärt eigentlich
soll es nur darum gehen irgendwelche
komischen produkte zu finden die mich
zum beispiel die habe ich wirklich
bestellt ich hoffe die kommen auf alle
oder zumindest kommen davon ein paar an
wie gesagt da gibt es auch wieder zu ich
bin jetzt natürlich auch ich bin jetzt
ich bin jetzt natürlich auch nicht blöd
und gebt 1600 euro für sachen aus die
nicht haben möchte
allerdings habe ich mir jetzt gerade
überlegt eine sache davon kaufen wir
oder was dann wenn wir den teppich
ja okay dann nehmen wir dieses ding
willst du das am liebsten
also spielt jetzt einfach mal mit auf 70
euro und es geht noch fünf stunden die
die option dann ja leute das was mit dem
video ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen bei
10.000 lecks gibt es die nächste folge
und zwar habe ich geplant
das allerdings ist abgesehen von diesem
zeug hier zufällig pizza bestellen da
bin ich aber gespannt wir sehen uns
morgen wieder wahrscheinlich ich wünsche
euch noch einen angenehmen tag also und
bieten und ob ihr das portemonnaie oder
was noch immer dass es wirklich bekommen
haben können wir auf snaptu histogramm
sehen da kann ich mir auf jeden fall
folgen
wir sehen uns herein bis morgen